are we capable now to do uh a robot that
is self-aware
that's that's one the legged one i need
uh
it's self-aware like it's not a
self-aware it's been listening but it's
not self-aware but do you think a human
being is self-aware or that's a good
question
i mean i ask this question all the time
when the robots move there's a sense of
when they turn on
something entered that robot
wow and when it turns off something left
uh if they move in a certain kind of way
and if they're if they surprise you
there's certain elements
that enable us
to see the magic in
in a living being and some of them i
mean we can character we can maybe list
them
but it's the ability to surprise you
it's the
ability to make mistakes and learn from
them visibly there's a bunch of things
that you just
i don't know it just feels
like it has the magic of what is a
living being
and which is what humans have and i try
to think about how do you replicate that
into a machine
so when you turn it on enough you feel
like it it dies every time and it re
reborn right so for most machines we
don't feel that way we don't when we
unplug things
we don't feel that way i don't know why
we don't feel that way that's an
interesting question
but i think when
when the robot has certain qualities
like memory
like ability to recognize you
yeah you start to feel like you're
turning off an organism so so whenever i
have like the robots that recognize me
and remember
this is important
that all the things we've experienced
together
then it's like holy
that's a that's a living thing but does
he really feels it feels like a living
thing does he remember
your robot does he remember things that
happened before you unplugged him is it
like he's sleeping
like
you wake up or is he like that so right
now start to zero everything uh no it
doesn't start at zero remember it
remembers everything that's the key
every time you like you you unplug wow
it's storing the story in the memory but
the memories are basic they're like okay
we walked around the kitchen and then um
you looked at me i mean the memories
it's like data it's just
it's not like we've experienced it's
able to actually
uh experience anything deep like we
humans can but just the fact of memory
it's like the toaster or the microwave
don't don't give a about me
they don't know me they don't know me by
name they wouldn't recognize my face
as being different from gordon's they
wouldn't know the difference and they
wouldn't
remember
the microwave currently doesn't remember
you know the times i've been sad or
happy
like what food i put into it it doesn't
remember this
when i was being a fat ass or what i was
being in good shape and
all
just those memories are enough to make
you feel when you turn a thing off
it's like
wow that's a living that's that
that's a living thing disappearing of
course that's kind of an
anthropomorphism we do to each other
but uh that's something it's you know
that
that's some that makes me believe it's
possible to create um
systems with which we can have a
connection that are non-human like
similar to dogs and cats and so on just
makes me
and that's what's interesting to me
because ultimately i feel like they'll
help us understand
ourselves